l'union européenne attend beaucoup de sa
nouvelle relation avec les états unis
les décisions trump yen reste encore en
travers de la gorge le soutien aux
partisans d'un bric site dur ou encore
les tensions commerciales avec
l'allemagne aujourd'hui deux domaines
inévitable devrait s'imposer comme une
préoccupation commune la lutte contre le
coran navires us et le changement
climatique
joe biden qui a promis que les états
unis réintègrerait l'accord de paris sur
le climat notre engagement commun est
essentiel dans un monde où les
puissances autoritaires cherchent à
subvertir les démocraties reste à savoir
comment s'y prendre pour éviter une
mauvaise communication
point positif les européens discuteront
à nouveau avec des interlocuteurs jugé
fiable
le futur secrétaire d'état anthony
blinken qui est francophone et a vécu à
paris dans sa jeunesse et le bras droit
de ben hayden depuis près de 20 ans by
donne est un peu désorientés face à la
complexité européenne
les américains ont toujours l'impression
que c'est très lent avec l'union
européenne
pour eux c'est plus simple d'appeler
londres ou paris ou berlin
plutôt que de s'adresser à l'union
européenne si bruxelles pourrait bien
être la première visite diplomatique du
futur président pas sûr que le lieu soit
sa priorité
les etats unis risquent bien être
accaparé pendant les prochaines années
par l'asie et notamment les ambitions
chinoises croissante